STEPHEN FLUIN: Good afternoon,
and welcome everyone.
My name is Stephen Fluin.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Angular team at Google.
When I talk about
my role to people,
they're often a
little bit surprised
by what a developer advocate
on the Angular team does.
The Angular team, overall,
is relatively small.
But I really have two missions.
My first mission is to help the
community build great Angular
applications, and use
Angular to build great apps.
My second mission is to listen
and understand the challenges
that the developers go
through on an everyday basis,
and then reflect those needs
within the Angular team,
because only by
understanding what's
going on in the real
world can we really
build the right framework,
and the right platform
to make everyone
else successful.
So I don't know how many of you
were listening in the keynote,
or attending any of the
Angular tracks earlier today,
but I'm going to start off
with a brief introduction
to Angular, for those of you
that may not be familiar.
So I like to say that Angular
exists to make building
applications with the web easy.
And so I use these
words very carefully,
because the web
is a platform that
is one of the most powerful
platforms for delivering
content and interactivity
that has ever existed.
But the web is also changing.
There's new frameworks
coming out all the time.
There's new ways of
building applications.
There's new standards for
things like JavaScript,
and for bundling
your applications.
And so when we
think about Angular,
the Angular team
is thinking about,
how do we react to the
web as it is today?
And build a framework that makes
your lives a little bit, easier
and tries to solve
some of the problems
that you face everyday, by being
a little bit more opinionated.
And so one example of that
opinionation that we see
is that we believe
applications should
be written to live everywhere.
And so when we think about
building an application
we want to be able to use the
same code to build your web
application that might be
rendering on a desktop.
Or, as we think about the
majority of use cases,
rendering out to mobile devices.
And so this means
things like performance
are very, very important to us.
And it also means that
things like taking advantage
of the latest and
greatest of the web,
such as progressive
web applications
is also a very
important part, that we
feel is critical to
our strategy of helping
you connect to users, and
deliver great experiences.
I'm going to talk through this
in about four different parts.
So hopefully you guys have some
background on progressive web
applications, because I'm going
to assume that most of you
have heard about some of
these concepts before.
And I'm going to talk about
them in how they specifically
apply to Angular.
So I'm going to start off
talking about app shells.
Then I'm going to move
into service workers,
and how to register
service workers.
And then I'm going
to talk about how
Angular tries to encapsulate
push notifications.
And then together, hopefully
with a little bit of luck,
we're going to do
some live coding.
And we will build an Angular
application from scratch.
And then we will
add a service worker
to give it some
additional capabilities,
and really try and take
it out of the realm of web
application, into kind of this
progressive web application
concept.
I will say, as a little
bit of a preface,
that from the Angular
team's perspective,
these things are experimental.
So while we have a lot of
great working code examples,
and there are
companies using all
of these concepts
in production today,
we are still aware that
the developer experience
can be improved.
And we're spending a
lot of time and energy
on making that experience
better for everyone here.
An example of that, that I'm
going to demonstrate a little
bit, is the use of what
we call the Angular CLI,
which is a command line
environment that helps you both
scaffold out new applications,
but it also helps you to run
these applications, so that
you're getting this live
development editing
and environment,
but then also helps you
ship great applications,
in terms of delivering
production ready minified,
compiled JavaScript
bundles, , out to the users,
in the best way possible, with
a service worker, ideally.
And so I'm going to show
you tools that work today,
and that will work.
But you can also expect
over the coming months
to see all of these
tools get baked
into our standard set of tools.
Because when I think about
progressive web applications
I see a future where every
web application should be
a progressive web application.
There's almost, pretty soon,
going to be very little,
or no excuse of why
you wouldn't want
to do this, because in
every case, the only impact
that your additional things
like a service worker
are going to have are to improve
the experience for your users,
and deliver better outcomes
for you as a developer.
So let's get into the
first section here.
App shell generation.
So just a brief highlight of
what we believe an app shell
is.
An app shell is a
set of static HTML
that is rendered
on the server side,
and delivered down to
the user, to give you
the quickest, fastest
time to first paint,
and time to first interactivity.
And so many firmwares do these
things in different ways.
But the primary way that
Angular thinks about doing this
is with a project that we
have called Angular Universal.
And so Angular
Universal is a project.
It's an open source project,
as with all of Angular,
that is designed to allow you
to run Angular applications,
and render them
fully server side,
and then deliver down to the
browser, a fully rendered HTML
document, then bootstraps
Angular on top of it,
trying to balance both the
high performance, and ready
availability of that HTML.
But then also the interactivity
and the same development
experience that you have with
any normal Angular application.
And so if you're looking at
Angular- and we actually,
in the Angular
track earlier today
we actually heard from a
couple of companies in China
that are using Angular
universal today to deliver
these types of experiences.
So that was really
great to hear.
So when we think about Angular
Universal, what we're doing
is we've got a
de-coupled DOM model.
And so what that means is,
when you build an Angular
application, all of the logic,
all of the change detection
that happens within
your application,
is not happening on a DOM level.
We first acknowledge the
kind of, more pure concept
of your component hierarchy,
and then we figure out
what changes have happened
within your component
hierarchy, and then we propagate
only those changes back using
a renderer out to the DOM.
So we don't use a virtual DOM.
We do it all in the pure, kind
of ES6, class and module world.
And what that
allows us to do is,
that allows us to run,
similar to many frameworks,
the entire application in the
server, and then ship it down.
But the other thing
that we can do
is, because we're running
Angular fully on the server,
is we can apply Angular
logic to some of the things
that you're building
your applications with.
So this is an example
of an app shell module.
And so you're going to
see a few things here.
At the top, you're going
to see the app shell
module that we're importing
from the Angular project.
And then we're going
to be importing that
into our specific module.
So you see here we've
got this app module
and it is importing
the app shell module.
So what that does is that
gives us a set of directives,
and capabilities, to render
Angular in different ways
depending on the type of
environment we are in.
And so this sets
the stage for us,
and then we move that forward
into a set of directives.
And I'll make this
bigger in a second.
So this is a standard,
relatively simple, template.
So we've got a header section.
We're writing this
in HTML, so we're
anticipating it being rendered
to the DOM at some point here.
You've got normal Angular
style event handlers,
such as these click handlers.
Then I've got a
main section where
I want to render
out, for example,
the subcomponents
called weather cards.
And then I have a loading bar.
And then I've got a city
picker at the bottom.
And so what you're
going to notice here
is in this middle
section, we actually
have two very intentionally
designed directives.
So you're going to see star
shell no render here, and star
shell render.
And what this allows us to
do is, because with Angular
Universal you're rendering
on the server side,
we can actually determine
which parts of your template
should be rendered, as
part of that app shell,
and ship down to the browser,
and which parts should not.
And so in this case,
shell no render means
do not render this if
we are in an app shell.
And shell render means do render
it if we're in an app shell.
And so what this
looks like is we
will not see that shell
no render component,
but we will see the
loading bar here.
And then we have any of
the other HTML that we put,
which is going to be
there in either case.
And so what we've actually done,
using Angular Universal here,
is we figured out, based on
the directives that you've
set on your
templates, regardless
of what routing you're using,
or how complex your application
is, we figured out what
are the critical path, DOM
tree, and the CSS required
for those components,
and we've included
those into the app shell
that we then render, and
ship down to the browser.
And so when I first
heard about this,
it sounds a little bit magic.
But many people already maintain
their own app shells by hand.
And so this is just a
little bit of a tool
to help manage those
sorts of things,
and to make our lives
as developers just
a little bit easier.
So second, I want
to talk about one
of the most important parts
of building a progressive web
application, and that's the
usage of its service worker.
So just like any
application that you're
building with the
web, you're going
to want to check to see
if a service worker is
available within the current
browser that the user is using.
And then we are going
to register this.
But we're going to register
this thing called worker-basic.
And so what I'm going
to demo in a little bit
is the way that we generate
that worker-basic for you,
in a way that is
going to, we hope,
automatically figure out
what's in your application,
and how it needs to be
rendered, how it needs
to be cached for your users.
So we're trying to keep this
step as simple and as standard
as possible.
And then we're trying to do
a little bit of the magic
on the back end, in the same
way that SW pre-cache does
for generic, kind of
non-framework applications,
in a very Angular
specific context.
One of the things
behind the scenes that
allows us to generate
that service worker basic
is this idea that we
have an Angular service
worker manifest.
And so one of the fantastic
parts of building a single page
application is that we can use
this idea of HTML-5 push state.
So this is the idea that I can
have a single page application,
where all of my JavaScript
is loading in one place,
and then using URLs to
map into that state.
I can change what
the user is viewing.
And so one of the things that
our service worker manifest
does right now is it
tells the service worker
which routes it should
listen for, an intercept.
So if anyone has built a
single page application
and deployed that onto
Roku, or Firebase, or any
of these kind of
content platforms,
one of the things
you had to do is
you had to intercept
any non-slash,
or slash index that HTML URLs,
and serve up the right page.
And so what this
allows us to do is
this allows us to do the
same thing within the service
worker.
And so this is an
example of an area
that we're trying to make
the tooling much better,
because right now this file will
work for your basic routes so,
your slash route,
but we feel that we
can should be automatically
generating, or automatically
interpreting in
this file for you,
based on the routes
of your application.
Because we have this
statically analyzable
set of routes within your
application typically,
and so we should be able
to figure out for you what
the routes are, and then
automatically intercept those
in the service worker for you.
The second step here, in
having a service worker
within an Angular
application today
is we have a very simple gulp
task that we've provided.
So once again, we're working
to embed this into our CLI.
But we also want to make
sure that we're doing it
in the right way,
and not limiting
these sorts of capabilities
to only those that
are using the CLI,
because we understand
that a lot of Angular developers
are not yet using the CLI.
But basically what
this gulp task does
is it will process all
of the static files that
match a specific type
within your application.
So you can specify file
names, or file types,
and then we will
automatically add that
to the service worker cache.
And so then, you saw
this in the last session,
when you look at
the application,
and see what your browser
is actually storing,
you'll see that we automatically
update those caches
as soon as a new service
worker manifests,
or service worker
has been deployed.
One of the things that
we are working on as well
is the idea of dynamic
content caching.
So what we would like to do
is every time your Angular
application encounters
a URL that it has
to load from the
internet, we want
to give you the options to
look at the headers of that,
and obey their caching
policy, but then
use the service worker to do
that level of dynamic content
caching.
So to visualize that further,
if you build an application that
pulls a data set from
an adjacent web server,
or backend, we would
like to give you
the power, and the ability,
to monitor that request,
and funnel that request
through the service worker,
and then if you choose to, cache
that request automatically.
So this is something
that, if you follow
the @angular/angularchangelog,
or any of our release
announcements,
you'll see very soon.
And then the final section
here that I want to talk about
is the idea of
push notifications.
So for those of you that may
be less familiar with Angular,
we are big fans of
the concepts of RXJS,
which is basically observables,
or streams of information.
And so as you
might expect, we've
represented a lot of
push notifications,
and some of those
capabilities, as observables.
I have a slide at the
end that shows you
a working demonstration with
push notifications, in this way
that I'm talking about here.
But very similar to
our app shell module,
we're going to pull in our
service worker module, which
is, we're going to use
dependency injection to add
to our app component.
And then we're going to call
that service, that Ng service
worker, we're going to
say register me for push.
And then what
you'll get back is,
you'll get back a Ng service
worker dot push object.
And so this is going to be
an observable of messages.
And because it's
an observable, that
means you can subscribe to that.
You can merge it with
other data sources.
Or you can do any sort
of reactive programming
that you want to go a little
bit beyond just showing this
as a notification at
the top of the screen.
And so we're working
very hard to give you
control of what goes on.
So for example, if your
application is offline,
so the user is not interacting
with it, so to say,
then obviously it's going to
just come in as a notification.
But if your user is interacting
with your application
at the time, a push
notification comes in,
we want to give you that as
a different type of message,
and then possibly give you
a different channel for how
to deal with that message.
And so if we look at
what it would actually
look like in an app
component to use these things
I would first pull in
the Ng service worker,
by a dependency injection.
I would double check to make
sure the service worker exists
within the browser
that I'm running in.
And then I would
register for push
as part of the constructor.
So as part of setting up the
application for the first time.
And then I would take,
and I would then also
be able to scan, or
listen to that observable,
and then I can push that
out into a new array.
So scan is an operator
on an observable
that stacks up all of the
things that have come before it.
So every time a new
push notification
comes in this
messages array would
contain all of the messages
received to date, for example.
So with that brief intro out
of the way what I want to do is
I want to actually get into
a live application with you,
build it from scratch, pull
in some data via the web,
add material design, get
something that looks OK
and functions well.
And then I want to go
ahead and use these tools
that I've talked about,
and add a service
worker on top of that.
So let's dive in.
I've just got to set
up my microphone here.
All right.
Can you guys hear me like this?
This is a Jerry-rigged
little device.
All right.
So the first thing I need is a
brand new Angular application.
And because I'm not assuming any
network connectivity right now
I took a moment before
we started here,
and I basically
typed two commands.
I typed Ng new,
GDD, which creates
a new project called GDD.
And then it
automatically went ahead
and installed all of the
NPM, or dependencies,
that this application
would need to run.
So I did the network
intensive part before coming.
But if we look at
this we're actually
going to see a very blank
starter Angular application.
So I'm going to spin up a
server here by typing Ng serv.
That what we should
be able to do
is, we should be able
to open the source code,
and I'll give you a brief look.
So we're doing a demo for GDD.
So for those of you that
haven't used the CLI before,
the CLI's scaffolding
capabilities
are very powerful, in
terms of the way that it's
going to give you all of
the complex parts of web
development now.
So all of the testing
infrastructure, all the testing
configuration, the get ignores.
Because we're big
fans of TypeScript
it's going to give
you all the TypeScript
configurations for you.
And it will even make
the first commit for you,
if you want it to do so.
And then if we move up a
layer into source slash app,
we're going to see
the core of what
is our Angular application.
So at the top level,
we have a module
that was generated for us.
And it pulls in some things
that people commonly need,
such as forms, such as HTTP
for making network requests.
And then it's bootstrapping
to this initial app component.
And so that app
component is where we
put most of our functionality.
So we'll see here, it's a ES6
class with a decorator on it
telling it what each HTML
to use for its template,
what CSS to use, and then
how to bind into the DOM.
So let's change this here.
So let's build an application
about things to do in China.
All right.
So if we save that here,
and if our terminal
was successful in
the background here,
we should be able to
go to our local server,
and see a working Angular
application with that title.
And so one of the first
things that I always
do when I am touching
a new application
is I actually add material
design, because this is a very
easy to way to go from having a
design that does not look very
good, which is
typically my designs,
and then add
something that tries
to use the best of what
Google is designing,
in terms of material design.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to import from Angular
slash material,
and I'm going to import
that material module.
And don't worry about
taking pictures.
All of this code will be on
GitHub after the presentation.
So I'm going to add
here, a material module.
I'm going to say for
root, because we're
calling it in a root component.
And then, now that I
have materials then,
I need to add a theme for it.
So I've just got a tiny
bit, a snippet of CSS
here, that I'm
going to paste in.
This basically
resets the margins.
Gives me a little bit of padding
on buttons, and on cards,
and then pulls in that
theme as we talked about.
And so now, let's also take
advantage of that material
design that we've just imported.
So I'm going to go to
my HTML, and instead
of having a simple H1 tag, I'm
going to add an MD toolbar,
and I'm going to give
it a color matching
the primary color of our theme.
Toolbar.
Just close out the
MD toolbar tag here.
So what we've done
is, this color
refers to the primary color that
was imported from our theme,
and then MD toolbar
is a material design
toolbar that looks
a little bit better
than just the standard H1.
So now at the top
of our screen, we
have this relatively nice
looking, "Things To Do
In China" app introduction.
So from there what I
want to do is I actually
want to pull in a
couple of things
that would normally be
pulled from the internet.
So namely, a list of
things to do in China,
and some images that
correspond with them.
So let's go ahead and
copy those things.
So I'm going to go into our
source slash assets folder,
and I'm going to copy from--
I think.
Yep so star dot jpg.
We'll just copy all
the images, and then I
will copy our China
places JSON file.
All right.
So those things would
typically be hosted on the web,
but I'm trying to do this in
an entirely localized way.
But now we've got
a JSON file that's
going to be served
via the internet.
And so I need to pull that
JSON file into my application.
And so what I can
do is, I can use
that HTTP module that we talked
about a little bit earlier.
So I'm going to pull in
HTTP, from Angular HTTP.
And then in our
constructor I'm going
to use dependency injection
to get a handle on that it
HTTP service.
And then once I have that I
can define a local variable,
such as places.
Or a member variable
on our component,
and then I will
go ahead and add,
or I will retrieve
that set of places.
So I'll say, this dot
places equals HTTP dot get.
And it's going to be in assets
slash-- what did we call it?
I think it was China
dash places dot JSON.
And then we'll all just want
to throw a quick map on here
to get the JSON of the response.
All right.
So now, we should
theoretically have
a list of places that is
an observable emitting that
list as soon as the HTTP
request is completed.
But now we actually want to
go ahead and render that list.
So let's go ahead into
our app component.
And let's first just
throw a div on here.
And I'm going to use what we
call a structural directive
called and Ng four.
And I'll say what
place of places.
And I'm going to automatically
DA sync this request.
And then let's say,
place dot name.
All right.
So if I've done this correctly
what we should be getting
is a HTTP request gets made
to China dash places dot JSON.
And then that should be
iterated over asynchronously,
and then be rendered
out to the page.
So let's take a look.
All right.
We now have a very
simple list of things
that we can do in China.
But let's go ahead and make
this a little bit prettier,
because once again, you
should not trust my design.
So I'm going to use
something called an MD card.
And I'm going to put this
into an MD card header.
And we'll say MD card content.
And we'll put the
place dot description.
I'll just complete
the task here.
All right.
So now we're going to be using
a material design card, instead
of a simple div file.
All right.
So now this looks a
little bit better.
But I think we can
do even one better.
So here I'm going
to use an image tag.
And I'm going to use a material
design directive called MD card
image.
And I'm going to bind the source
attribute to our assets folder,
plus the place dot image URL.
And what this
directive should do
is, it should make it
everything render nice and full,
and we should be seeing
that nice picture.
So effectively, that
is our application.
So it now works.
It should render
relatively well on mobile,
if we consider a
normal looking device.
And so now let's try
turning this into more
of an advanced web application.
And so the first
thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to pull in a
very basic manifest file.
So I'm going to once again copy
from my little magic folder
here, a manifest.
So if we look at what
I just pulled in,
this is a GDD, Things
To See In China app,
and I have supplied an icon.
I've supplied some
colors for it, as well.
But we also have
to reference that.
So I've got a
little snippet here.
So we can pull
that into our HTML.
So I'm just going to put it
next to this other link here.
All right.
So there are a couple
other dependencies now
that we want to get a
little bit more advanced,
and do things like
adding a service worker.
So there's angular
slash service worker
project that I've already
added to our project here.
So if you see Angular
slash service worker,
I've already used
NPM to add that.
As well as dependencies,
such as gulp.
And so now what
I'm going to do is
I'm going to copy a very generic
gulp task, and a service worker
configuration, into
our project again.
So we're going to
copy the gulp file.
And we're going to copy
the Ng SW manifest.
So just like I showed you
earlier in the slides,
we're only going to
intercept the slash.
So we're not going to intercept
any other special routes,
and override them.
And we're going to see
a relatively simple gulp
file, where we want to look
for any HTML, CSS, JavaScript,
as SEGs, JSON files, JPEGs.
So just a list of
standard files that
might be in our application.
And then last,
what we need to do
is, we need to make sure
that our service worker is
registered on our page.
We're going to, again,
modify the index HTML file.
Right before the
end of the head I'm
going to include our
script differ, where
we check if there's
a service worker,
and then we register using that.
All right.
So we've done a few extra
steps here, and copied
some very boilerplate code.
Once again, these
are things that we
want to help automate for you.
But they're relatively
simple to do.
So let's go ahead
now, and take this out
of live development mode.
And what I actually
want to do is,
I want to do a full
production build.
So I'm going to, again,
use the command line.
And I'm going to say
Ng build AOT prod,
and I'm going to call my
gulp task called, enhance.
And so what this
is going to do is
this is going to
take my code, it's
going to compile all of the
templates, all the CSS, down
into JavaScript, into
what we call Ng factories.
It's going to minify the
code, pull out any comments.
It's going to do a
little bit of ugly-fying,
a little bit of tree shaking,
store that entire application
into the slash disk
folder, and then render out
the service worker based on
the files as they were then.
So the Angular CLI is finished,
and our gulp task is finished,
so let's check our disk folder.
And let's actually go
ahead, and serve this.
So I'm going to use Python, just
because I find that Python is
on every computer I ever touch.
And I'm going to use
a simple HTTP server.
So now, when I access
local host 8,000,
we should see the
same application.
But if we look in
the developer tools
we should now see that we've
registered a service worker.
And that service
worker should be doing
all of the caching for us.
Pulling in these images,
pulling in the JSON
file that we were pulling.
And then, for example, if I
want to take this application
offline, so now I want
to actually go out
into China, where I may not
have an internet connection,
and I want to still be able to
pull up all of this content,
and I do a refresh, it
should still be there.
So the entire application
is now running offline,
stored on my device, and
because we have that nice, web
app manifest, we're
going to get all
of the appropriate
lightning scores.
I think this thing, this
app gets about a 77,
if I remember correctly.
And there's more that you
can do to optimize it.
But it's very, very
easy to get started.
So that was our application.
Let me just jump back
to the slides here.
So all of today's code,
it's not there yet,
but it will be in my GitHub
repo there, 2016 PWA Beijing.
And then if you want to see all
of the more advanced features,
such as app shell generation,
we have another sample there
that you can take a look at.
So I will take
questions offline.
So if you guys want to come up,
thank you so much for coming.
Sure.
I can try and take
questions now.
Should we also do the lightning
score, and see how we do?
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
AUDIENCE: So this is a very
specific question about--
So the question is, even if
the data is bound in Angular,
does somehow the page does
not refresh, or updated.
So the question is
wondering if any site that--
STEPHEN FLUIN: So the
page will what refresh?
AUDIENCE: It's not
updated, or refreshed.
STEPHEN FLUIN: So what the
service worker basic does
is it will proxy requests,
and if something is not
found in the cache, then it
will go out to the internet,
and try and fetch that for you.
But one of the reasons that
I'm a big fan, personally,
of observables is that you
can actually mix and match
data sources.
So for example, in
several applications
that I've seen built, you can
combine a observable stream
coming from a HTTP request,
that may or may not
be cached locally, with
perhaps local storage, which
should be in memory.
But it might be faster than a
local service worker request,
with a full web request out
to a third party service.
So observables, and the
ability to merge observables
into a single, kind of, event
emitter, or a single subject,
is one of the most
powerful things.
And that would be one way to
achieve this idea of combining
the local cached version,
and with an attempt
to get something fresher.
AUDIENCE Hi.
I have one question.
And PWA, and Angular--
STEPHEN FLUIN: Could you speak
a little bit louder please?
AUDIENCE: OK.
Sorry.
And PWA, and Angular can
be used Chrome, Explorer.
And I want to know how it can
be used in Adroid WebView,
could we support good?
STEPHEN FLUIN: So
Angular is going
to be identical to any
other framework, or even
pure JavaScript, when it
comes to browser support.
So we're going to--
I love the idea of progressively
enhanced applications,
because you can add a service
worker to an application,
and if service workers are
available in that context,
so I know more and more
Android WebViews are
kind of being served by
Chrome, instead of Android.
I think that that's a
legacy that's slowly fading.
But it's not an Angular
specific problem.
AUDIENCE: How about PWA?
PWA in Android WebView.
STEPHEN FLUIN: In
Android WebView?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
STEPHEN FLUIN: Do you
know what version?
I think it works.
I always use, caniuse.com,
or Is Service Worker Ready,
are two resources
that you can see.
So Angular is not going to get
in the way, or help in any way.
If PWAs work in Android,
which I believe they
do in four and above, maybe.
AUDIENCE: I don't
remember the exact--
STEPHEN FLUIN: They
may work, they may not,
but as more Android devices
continue getting updated,
things will get better.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And another question, I have
application use Angular,
and use Angular with
Android WebView,
but sometimes when I
load a URL this will
shows a gap in the WebView.
STEPHEN FLUIN: Like a--
AUDIENCE: An outer--
STEPHEN FLUIN: A space, or
a gap, in terms of time?
AUDIENCE: A very short time,
about one or two seconds.
One or two seconds.
And there's a date, and it
says, hi, our Javascript
will be load.
STEPHEN FLUIN: Sure.
So and that's why an app
shell is really important,
because that app shell
is what should get you,
instead of a gap, it
should get you something
meaningful on the page,
that tells the user,
this application is loading.
So for example,
in my application
we just had the word loading,
which is not a great app shell,
by any means, but if you could
render, for example, the title
bar, just a flat
image, or excuse me,
a flat background, which is
one line of CSS, then the user
feels like something's coming.
And then the faster
we can swap that out
with actual content, the better,
which is why service worker is
great, because service worker
means we don't have to do
a full network round trip.
We can just get that from local
cache, and then render it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And is there any better
solution about this?
STEPHEN FLUIN: So the
question is, do we have
a better solution for the gap?
AUDIENCE: Cause my
application is about stock.
STEPHEN FLUIN: So
I mean, I think
the Chrome team, in general,
is fantastic at focusing
on metrics.
So we talk about
time to first paint,
and time to interactive,
which is you
only make them
better by writing,
kind of better app shells, and
by writing less JavaScript.
So on the Angular
side of things,
we're working on rendering as
little JavaScript as possible.
And we have a long
way to go there
to make it even
better than before,
and running less JavaScript.
But on the HTML side
of things, that's
going to be a subject of the
HTML you're able to craft,
and then the device's
ability to render it.
AUDIENCE: Okay.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I just want to toss
one thing in where I just
did a little quick searching.
And service workers
are supported
in Chrome WebView, starting
in Chrome WebView 40, right?
So if you are running a version
of Android that has the Chrome
WebView, and it is
version 40 or above,
you get the service
workers, and all the fun
stuff that goes along with that.
STEPHEN FLUIN: Build
it today, and every day
you will hit more users.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about it the SEO.
As we know, the Angular
is a good framework
so that we can use
[INAUDIBLE] banding.
But the problem is just
we have our website,
but the Google spider
cannot cache our website,
because they cannot do
anything with our JavaScript.
How can we deal with
the SEO problem?
STEPHEN FLUIN: So this is
common to many single page
applications, or
really any application
that is using JavaScript
to run its code.
There are a number
of different answers.
A growing percentage
of search engines
render JavaScript for you, and
understand the page perfectly.
But there are still search
engines that do not.
And for those there are things
like server side rendering,
either doing it yourself,
where you take control,
using a project such
as Angular Universal
to render the page on
behalf of your user.
There's also services out
there that will load your page,
and then store
that, and cache that
rendered version of your page.
So its a bit of a
hybrid approach.
So it's going to work
in many search engines,
especially the one I
use, and then there
are services if you
want to continue,
and take the performance
up to the next notch.
I Think there's time for
maybe one more question.
How are we doing?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Just a short one.
I saw you mentioning
this gulp task,
and I thought that Angular
2 was based on Webpack,
and I thought were
hopefully going to move away
from these kinds of things.
Now I just saw it.
I wasn't sure, is it just
related to your project,
or to Angular 2 in-general.
STEPHEN FLUIN: No.
So I'll clarify in
a couple of ways.
AUDIENCE: OK.
STEPHEN FLUIN: Angular 2 is not,
in any way, built on Webpack.
We are agnostic of
module bundlers.
So there are a number
of good module bundlers
that have different trade-offs.
So in general, we tend
to think about Webpack,
which we use for the CLI.
And so we're big
fans of Webpack,
but you'll also see a lot
of our documentation written
for System JS,
because it's easier
to run System JS
in the client side,
and in different contexts.
There's also things
like roll up,
which allow you to do more
effective tree shaking,
and then finally things
like Closure Compiler,
which can do advanced
optimizations,
and probably achieve the
best level of tree shaking.
So Angular itself is
agnostic to how you bundle.
And in general, the module
bundling, and module loading
ecosystem is going to
undergo significant change
over the next six to 12
months, because there is not
yet a web standard for how
modules should be loaded.
Once that standard is
formalized, all of those tools
will probably update to comply.
And that world will change.
So first part, I love all
of my bundlers equally.
The second part is what I
demoed today is a gulp task,
but we are working to get
it to work as a plug-in.
And there are code
samples online
that if you ping me on an
GitHub I can help you find,
using Webpack today that do the
same service worker generation.
So where we're designing
these things independent
of the module bundler, so that
you can use them anywhere.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank
you very much.
AUDIENCE: Do you think Angular
2 needs some state management
framework, like Redux, or React?
If not, what's best practice
to manage is our model,
and to help?
STEPHEN FLUIN: So
we are opinionated
about a lot of things,
and we try and force you
down some paths that improve
your developer experience.
State management is one that
we are less opinionated about.
So we have a Redux
pattern library
called NGRX, that allows you
to set up all of the reducers,
and set up all the
actions that you want,
and use that exact same
pattern in a very Angular way.
You'll see that you can actually
use Redux within Angular.
So for example,
there's a project
called Apollo, which is
a graphical client that
uses Redox, and exposes
all of this content
to use transparently
within Angular apps.
But if you don't
want to use NGRX,
a lot of what's
built into Angular
is based on, if
you want it to be,
one way immutable
data structures.
So for example, what I showed
here was a observable of places
that would come in,
and then a component
that was unraveling that via the
async pipe, and showing that.
What would happen, because
we're using that one way
immutable dataflow is, if that
observable emitted a new value,
that component
would automatically
be updated without
reinstantiation.
So that's kind of this magical
world where, maybe we're
combining data from three
different sources, right?
We're combining it from a
memory cache, a disk cache,
and a full network request.
And then whatever resolves
first is going to be shown.
And then whatever
resolves second
is going to be shown second.
And then finally, that network
request is going to finish,
and then you'll have
the freshest data.
And you can propagate that back
into the appropriate caches.
And so Angular, as I talked
about in an Angular track
earlier today, is spending a
ton of time on making Angular
very, very fast,
and very performant.
And so we've built in this idea
of immutable data structures
into that model, where we don't
have to run change detection,
unless there's a new value.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
AUDIENCE: He's asking,
he did two things.
One, he is using Android
to develop a app.
Another is doing a web app.
But he feels like
he likes Angular,
but he's not sure that
Google is pushing for Angular
or the other cases, right?
Or in the future, or
maybe you can add it more.
AUDIENCE: He mentioned like,
some kind of develop framework
I'm not familiar with, React.
AUDIENCE: React.
Yeah, he has React.
STEPHEN FLUIN: So, maybe
I'll just try and answer
the question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
STEPHEN FLUIN: You can tell
me if I've misunderstood.
So when it comes to
bringing great experiences
to mobile devices, and
in particular, Android,
I definitely always
look to the web first.
For the reason being that you
still need a web application,
in most cases,
that you can't just
ship a native
installed application,
and hit the entire
market that you're
trying to capture anymore.
I think maybe four
or five years ago
you could just ship
a native application,
and not have a website,
but that's changed.
And I thought the
numbers this morning,
in the opening keynote
about 92% of users,
are using their mobile
devices, and not
necessarily in an installed app
mode, that was really telling.
But Angular, we do care
about this still installed
mobile feel.
And so there are
projects like Ionic,
or Onsen, that give you the
ability to ship a web view,
and so you get that
icon in the app store,
using, hopefully the
same code that you're
shipping on the web,
and shipping with a PWA,
to get that same experience.
But then there's also
ways, because of our DOM
independence, you can use
something like Native Script,
and render instead of to
DOM, and instead of to HTML,
you can render to
native UI elements.
And when it comes
to other frameworks,
you have to look at what
they're trying to achieve,
or what they're trying to be.
And in particular,
Angular's trying
to be a full platform
for building web
applications across the web.
In particular, I'm a big fan
of Polymer within Google.
Polymer is really based around
this idea of standardizing
on web components, which are
an emerging standard, that
are available in a growing
number of browsers.
So instead of relying on
something like Angular,
for a component, you can rely
on pure HTML, in a portable way.
And then what
Angular's trying to do
is, for example, we
can use web components
as leaf nodes in
a component tree,
and still get all of the nice
event binding, and property
binding, as you would get with
a normal Angular component.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
The last question.
AUDIENCE: Maybe this question
is very likely this person,
and I want to know, that
Angular very suitable for SPIA,
a single page application.
I want to know can you
provide the Android
[INAUDIBLE] packaging?
Will Android [INAUDIBLE]
library for Angular?
When I use Angular to some
[INAUDIBLE] with some coding,
I can call Android native view,
Android [INAUDIBLE] action.
Yes, so you can
you provide this?
STEPHEN FLUIN: Yes, so I think
I answered this a little bit
before, and I'll just
repeat that a little bit.
So there are many
projects out there
that help you build, and
ship Angular applications
as a installed mobile
application, which
is for Android Wear, you get
that app icon in the store.
And so there's
things like Ionic,
which is entirely
built on Angular 1,
originally, and
now on Angular 2.
There are things like Native
Script, that allow you
to render to native UI widgets.
But then there's
just general products
like Cordova, which are really
all about exposing native APIs,
in the JavaScript
world, and then allowing
you to ship that single page
application down as an app.
AUDIENCE: Maybe Ionic
package, Ionic program,
it not been known by Google--
maybe if Google, Google company,
provides another package,
another library,
set as this user,
official maybe the entire
[INAUDIBLE] powerful--
STEPHEN FLUIN: So you're
asking, when is Google
going to build one of those?
What I'll say is,
Angular has only
been successful over
the last seven years
because of an
ecosystem, and because
of things like developers
like yourselves have been
building to make it better.
So we do focus,
and we think about,
what should we be building?
But in general, we talk
to the team at Ionic,
we talk to the team at
Progress relatively often,
and we feel like they're
doing a great job,
and there's not really
a need that we can fill.
So maybe someday we'll
build something like that,
but we believe there's a lot
of companies out there, that
are doing a great
job, and we want
to recognize their efforts.
All right, thank you
so much everyone.
STEPHEN FLUIN: Thank
you, Stephen Fluin.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]